Bill Clinton is a very charismatic
person he is not glamorous I mean he
might be glamorous occasionally for five
minutes but basically you know we know
we too much about mental cleanse hi I'm
Ted bellacor with reason TV and today
i'll be speaking with virginia postural
posture l is a Wall Street Journal
columnist editor-in-chief of deep
glamour net and former editor-in-chief
of Reason magazine Oscar's just around
the corner so let's let's talk Oscars
some red carpet stuff I think it's
interesting it's something that I didn't
think much about before but anything
that any of us see on the red carpet at
the Oscars or anywhere can be and is
turned into a knockoff almost instantly
and it's legal can you explain how that
can be for complex reasons having to do
with the definition of clothes as
utility a fashion design is not
patentable the way a design for a
computer chip might be fashioned has
long been used by economists and others
who study intellectual property as an
industry that illustrates how you can
have massive amounts of innovation over
long period of time a sustainable
innovation without having strong
intellectual property protections there
are certain types of intellectual
property protections for certain
elements of fashion so in my most recent
wall street journal calm which was about
in incremental progress happen to quote
my brother I was talking about raincoats
and he works for the apparel division of
Merrill they recently got a design
patent for a jacket that can be turned
into a neck pillow you can do that
because it's a unique design but
something like and we were used to
stress as I us something like a wrap
dress ah which is an idea in the same
way that
a heist movie as an idea is not you
can't copyright or patent the idea for a
certain style what's happened in recent
years is it as with so many other
industries is the frictions that used to
create a lag that allowed the original
creator to reap benefits have gone away
there was a long period of time between
the fashion show and when the knockoffs
would appear in you know Macy's that
were right cheaper but now whatever
matter report members you can get well
and not only what natalie portman
where's because what natalie portman
where's maybe something that was on a
runway what happens is people taking
pictures at the runway shows and
immediately knockoffs are being made now
a knockoff is not the same as the
original I mean and that's one reason
that you can't enforce what intellectual
property protections do exist let's take
something that natalie portman might
wear at the Oscars versus what somebody
the knock off somebody might where to
buy to wear to their prom well first of
all it will be made of a much cheaper
fabric the fabrication will be much more
cheaply done they'll be you know
there'll be no handwork even the machine
work will be the seams one piece sealed
is what anybody who knows garment
construction will be able to look even
at a nice life knock off and and tell
the difference but it's not only that
these knockoffs are not designed for the
same kinds of bodies they're not
designed for the same circumstances they
will have other differences they won't
be as low cut they the same the infamous
JLo dress is an infamous JLo dress if
you did a knockoff of that I don't know
that there were not relevant window down
to the belly button actually that fabric
may have been something that could be a
trademarked also because fabrics can a
fabric and low-end trademarks as well
the names of the brand yeah of course
they're the names of the brand about
someone
big part right what I write and post and
what's interesting to me is that the
award shows have become very much
fashion events i mean the fashion show
is ninety percent but listen well we
mentioned natalie portman i assume that
she's clearly glamorous crack there
which he is a kind of glamour all oh
gosh that would be a well well
interestingly it's interesting because
she as a person has a kind of glamour
she she wears clothes well she went
Harvard which you don't hear very often
to actresses since intelligent she has
made her mark however playing
unglamorous roles often Black Swan
obviously that's a very surf it's darkly
charmers yeah well it's there's a
glamour to the ballet that it's kind of
deconstructing and it's a horror movie
it's explicitly a horror movie and one
of the observations that I've made is
that horror is kind of the flip side of
glamour it's the unseen where the unseen
instead of just being boring which is or
work a day is actually terrible and then
I mean I really thought she was great in
V for Vendetta which again has this long
sequence where she's being starved and
she gets her hair shaved and so she she
there's a difference between the roles
they play out right exactly so she her
persona is uh is it interestingly sort
of more glamorous persona despite having
played these very unglamorous roles
which is interesting what would you say
about a fellow like Colin Firth because
he you see it seems like he's glamorous
today you see him on you know just up
all spiffy on the magazines and whatnot
but if he walked in to ihop he wouldn't
turn many heads if he was calling for
rent car sales he glamorous glamour
involves your ideal and they don't think
there are very many people who when they
think of an ideal type or a
representative of whatever it is that
they aspire to be or
personally I aspire to be with that
Colin Firth is who comes to mind now if
you aspire to be a very good actor or
something it could be glamorous in the
same way that you know if you aspire to
run libertarian TV on the web dream
glamour model you know so it so they're
different kinds of glamour but he is not
what I would consider to be sort of a
glamorous Hollywood a Hollywood star he
is a talented Hollywood star he's you
know they're mostly all good-looking is
it something that you can create or you
just aren't certainly in the old studio
days the studio's did a lot to try to
glamorize their stars and there are
choices that individual actors can make
them will make them more or less
glamorous one is how much they just
closed about themselves glamour always
requires a certain element of mystery so
if you are always yourself i'm not
talking about what the tabloids chase
you because that no one ever knows if
it's really true or not but but if you
yourself are in the sort of confessional
mode all the time or or having meltdowns
in public no matter how beautiful you
are and how great you wear dresses or
whatever you're probably not going to be
glamorous or if you are you're likely to
lose it and the interesting example is
JLo who kind of had it lost it from
overexposure and then over a long period
of time kind of rebuilt it slowly slowly
slowly and her his gym maybe JLo is a
model for President Obama because I know
you've said that he started off as a
candidate is very glamorous and then
when reality hits it's sort of like the
more glamorous they are the harder they
fall it's a little hard when you're
president because you can't just
withdraw to your house on Long Island or
wherever she lives and and and sort of
be away from the public mean what makes
what makes it hard to maintain glamour
as a president is that you have to
actually make political choices or even
the failure
make political choices is a choice and
and when you make choices or you don't
make choices you will alienate some of
the people who expected you to behave
differently even the public that voted
for Obama and is likely to vote for
Obama again I think they're sort of not
looking for the jury you so much so so
it does that explain the appeal of
someone like a governor chris christie
he doesn't he doesn't strike me as
glamorous but there's something there
yeah people he has a speech at American
Enterprise Institute and people treat it
like it's American Idol or so right well
well first of all very important than
political context is there's a
difference between glamour and charisma
usually when we talk about political
figures we talk about charisma and
there's a good reason because charisma
is actually a rare personal quality that
you know people just have it Bill
Clinton is a very charismatic person he
is not glamorous I mean he might be
glamorous occasionally for five minutes
but basically you know we know way too
much about Bill Clinton uh and and
always was him he was always like a
regular guy and chris Christie I think
has some charisma he says what he thinks
and and and right at this particular
moment people are I think a lot of
people want that kind of feeling of
being genuine you can list a whole lot
of people that people are talking about
right now there's a feeling that this
person says what he thinks and I'm in
the mood for that as opposed to being
told what I necessarily want to hear